matt foster who has been outstanding for
the sox both out of the bullpen
and as an opener quasi starter
so far in 2020. pitch down to edmond
ground ball sharply to first scooped up
there by abreu waving off any help he'll
take it to the bag himself that's how we
get underway here
in the first inning one away to bring up
matt carpenter 3-1 is on the ground
the second base danny mendick will feel
to the outfield grass and a strong throw
to first gonna be in time to up two down
here for the cardinals in the first
inning now here's paul goldschmidt swing
and a miss strike three off speed
and one two three go to the cardinals
here in the top half of the first inning
jake woodford the six for 220 pounder 23
years of
age to tampa florida one of the top
picks
a few years ago now making his major
league debut
the 2-0 pitch and a ground ball that's
hit to tommy edmund
up with it and he gets his first out
that's a nice job right there johan
mankata is coming to bed
slowly hit tough play here and he got
him
that's a tough play tommy edmond this
kid can play so exciting to watch play
that brings yasmani grandal to the plate
fastball grounded right to paul
goldsmith he said i'll take it he does
to the bag three and assisted good
inning good start jake
good start way to go we played one and
the cardinals went quietly in the first
and they'll send tyler o'neill brad
miller and dylan carlson to the plate
sharp ground wall to short fielded
cleanly there by anderson throw across
gonna be in time one away
here in the cardinals second inning
here's brad miller
back to foster who goes sky high to snap
it up
and throw out miller two down everything
just looks very
calm for matt foster he's been totally
undaunted
oh wave at a miss strike three the
change up fluttering through the breeze
second strikeout for matt foster that'll
end the cardinals second
are you playing first base in both the
first game and our second game
and a fastball goes inside a swing and a
miss so there's woodford's first major
league strikeout
that's an all-star jose abreu two outs
in the top of the third
next pitch to bader is bounced to the
left side and the play is made by
mankato and a wide throw and it gets
past abreu
and bader's heading for second base
there's a throw there and he's in
safely a wild throw for moncado who knew
he had to rush it
because of the speed of bader he really
forced that error
so back to the top now for edmond 3-2
pitch vader at second
and he draws the walk the cardinals now
have two base runners with two outs
but getting that third out is awful
awful tough at times
now it's a chance for matt carpenter in
the air center field
backing up on that one as louise robert
he'll make the catch running to the
right center field alley
cardinals strand their first two runners
of this game
see what woodford has in reserve after
six
up six down in the first two innings
let's see if luis robert can
supply the drive of the game high fly
ball to right center field
backing up now bader turning and
watching and it's gone
right center field a home run luis
robert that's his third of the year and
it puts the white sox in front
one nothing here in the third inning
paul goldschmidt to lead off this fourth
inning let's see if goldsmith can run
into one of those
and hit it 120 the other direction there
it is
hart hit the left field that's back
that's deep and that's gone
wow we asked for it and we got it home
run goldschmidt
and he has just tied this game in the
fourth inning time game 1-1 here's brad
miller now the 3-2 pitch
on the ground right side diving into a
stop at his medic spinning and throwing
and getting him at first base what a
play by mendic
got turned around as he was on a seat of
his pants
somehow able to get that ball over first
base in time to get miller for round
number two
now he walks grandal here's eloy jimenez
hits one of the air into right field
carlson started in now griff's back that
ball is carrying and it's gone
a two run homer for eli jimenez
and just like that the white sox have
recaptured the lead at three
and matt carpenter comes to the plate
with two runners aboard and just one out
in the cardinals fifth
and carpenter hits it to the right side
and with that that will score bader
now three to two white sox and paul
goldschmidt with homerd
just an inning ago will bat against evan
marshall
up the middle and it's a base hit
this game is tied goldschmidt has tied
it up
it's 3-3 tyler o'neill the batter this
might be your guy right here
why don't you just go out on a limb and
say this is your guy well this might be
the guy he can do it off him
all right in the air deep left field at
the wall
gone my man
what were you saying you could just see
it coming tyler o'neill two-run
homer and giving the cardinals the lead
here in the fifth inning
and dylan carlson looking for his first
major league hit
carlson hits it out to right base head
his first major league hit
carlson around first base miller to
third
dylan in safely at second base dylan
carlson
with his first major league hit it's a
double one out
second and third here's brad miller
and miller it's a high fly ball
out to deep right at the wall and it's
caught
up against the wall carpenter will tag
the cardinals have
a 6-3 lead they always lethal
andrew miller is on the white sox down
to their final out here in game two
edwin encarnacion will represent that
chance
a swing and a miss for a red bird winner
and the cardinals have swept the
doubleheader
and their return to major league play